[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen hier heute
abend hier zu einem neuen blog da ist
jude jude und heute ist ein besonderer
tag denn meine schwester hat sie
geburtstag kann man bei klatschen das
heißt ich will selber gratuliere jetzt
mal kurz mal alles gute zum geburtstag
[Musik]
wir werden jetzt mit der ganzen familie
der kleinigkeit was essen fahren und
danach werde ich euch mal erzählen warum
im titel steht ihr bau heute fort leide
sachen nach beziehungsweise weiß ich
noch nicht genau was ein drittel stellt
aber irgendwas mit worten halt in real
life alterns nachbauen
alle zusammen
wieder zu hause angekommen freunde das
essen war einfach nur zu hause werden
allerdings nicht lange bleiben denn wir
haben und in einem supermarkt
beziehungsweise in ein bauhaus und jugel
was wenn wir machen
[Musik]
da bleibe ich hier auf meinem handy
bereits verschiedenste fortnight
heruntergeladen also diverse tests
werden wir nach bauen wir werden die
treppe nach bauen wir werden das medi
kit nachbauen wir werden die scp
aufbauen werden in buchschlag bauen wir
werden
chuck chuck nachbauen den flirt und das
war's also nicht alles davon wäre mir
nachbauen aber wir werden versuchen
davon einige dinge nachzubauen bevor
viren oder allerdings zum bauhaus fahren
werden
juli werden will was machen ein
interview mit sarah finden die sie sich
jetzt in einem jahr älter für alle damen
und herren für diese sequenz interview
in meinem blog habe ich mir extra
eingestellt ohne kabel
aber das kann auch die stimme verändern
also daran bisher jetzt 16 jahre alt
geworden darfst deswegen auch die 160
schauen
19 wurden wie fühlst du dich denn jetzt
mit 16
ich bin und wie fühlst du dich mit 16
16h viel party kannst du hast noch nicht
so ganz
apropos partie war anfangs ja freitag
auf deinen geburtstag richtig richtig
bedarf ich da mal alle leute hier
einladen
ok freunde am freitag alle nachbarn oder
alle eingeladen denkst du dass jule
schickte ich luke sonst etwas zu sagen
hast du dich denken wir das geschenk von
null und wir für dich gefreut
ich hab noch keins bekommen so auch
besser so weißt du was von uns bekommen
angekommen im baumarkt freunde juli
steht jetzt wo wir haben uns eine
riesige notiz angefertigt wieder die
schule mit allen möglichen sachen die
wir irgendwie brauchen die sache es hat
der auch nachbauen wollten baden busch
und es ist eigentlich unnötig jetzt ein
buch zu kaufen
voll krass eigentlich dass die hier gras
verkauften bisheriger fortschritt
unserer baumarkt führen freunde wir
haben sekundenkleber um nägel die apa
noch zu hause auch die bretter
festzumachen wir haben gesagt du sollst
quadratisch schneiden nicht weiß nicht
was dann quadratisch nicht verstanden
hat das ist auf jeden fall für die
treppe also für die falle dass hier
haben wir das medi kit da werden wir
dann noch weiß es mit einer weißen farbe
das irgendwann mal dann haben wir hier
noch so klebeband gekauft weil das rote
brauchen wir beispielsweise für die
verbände da wir allerdings in den
baumarkt hier nicht alles kriegen werden
werden wir jetzt noch zu verschiedenen
supermärkten fahren und da den rest
einkaufen
[Musik]
wir sind wieder zu hause angekommen
freunde und wir haben ordentlich viele
sachen eingekauft das ist übrigens keine
produktplatzierung irgendeine macke
libyen benutzen ja mit zwei mal so ein
blaues biermischgetränk eingekauft weißt
einfach das einzige blaue getränkt war
was wir gefunden haben und supermarkt
dann haben wir hier eine orangene da
gekauft dann haben wir eine rote
[Musik]
aluminium bastl folie zweimal
verschiedenes klebeband dann haben wir
auch eine serie von zu hause und
verpackung caesar dann haben wir das
blatt papier eine am nebel box ein
das soll daher das medical darstellen
dann habe ich nochmal beladen glas und
soll zu fuß glas dann haben wir noch
eine küchenrolle und wir haben ein brett
und sekundenkleber und ein gewebe band
mit welchen leuten fangen wir an mit dem
blauen mit dem ich habe hier zwei bluter
es gibt banker rausgesucht und zwar
einmal den normalen zu laufen einmal
diesen job da der doccheck aber einen
normalen orangen hintergrund hat werden
wir den mit orangenen getränk darstellen
sei das einzig blaue gesenkt was wir
irgendwie supermarkt gefunden haben also
guckt aber wir machen jetzt dieses
getränk hat erst das ist doch das
einfachste was wir machen können und
zwar habe ich sagen die mir dafür dieses
hier
das sieht schon ähnlich aus das ist
tatsächlich dass alle einfachste dass
wir jetzt hier als erstes machen
also ich finde das hier einfach mal so
rein und das ist eigentlich dann auch
schon fertig haben noch in den deckel
blaues band stimmt nein
während ich erwarte dass dieser schaum
hier oben also ein bisschen weniger wird
weil wir sehen auch hier oben das da
oben eigentlich auch ein bisschen luft
entwickelt julia vorne den deckel in
blaues papier ein sehr gut machst du das
julia oder freunde noch mal so sieht der
surfer aus dem ford und die haben ihn
jetzt so nachgebaut ist eigentlich okay
oder
also wenn der vergleich dass kate also
in fordert verkennt man das also dass
die wahren und quasi produkts nummer
eins was ihr nachgestellt haben das
heißt er stellt jetzt mal nach hier
vorne im juli
was soll ich denn als nächstes nach das
medi kit
das hier ist das medical fortnight
freunde ich als richtig beschissen der
spieler muss das neue tief häufig
verwenden dafür haben uns diese brot
obst gekauft die kann man das noch mal
aufmachen
wir werden die halle 8 apropos da hat er
guckt sollen dann achtet man vielleicht
auch erst möglich doch da guckt so dass
ein kleiner verband raus aber wir werden
wir gleich die küchenrolle hier benutzen
allerdings werden wir erst mal diese box
wir gehen heute die nach viel papier
einpacken denn wir haben keine weiße
farbe so haben wir jetzt gerade guebuza
postbox ein bisschen mit weißem papier
ein gekleistert es sieht nicht gut aus
aber wir hatten einfach keinen bock uns
ein richtiges medi kit zu kaufen es geht
ja heute um es nachbauen also so weit
sind wir jetzt gerade deswegen so soll
es aussehen also soweit werden wir
wahrscheinlich nie kommt das heißt als
nächstes müssen wir sollen rotes tuch
entwickeln und zwar haben wir uns dafür
so rotes wasser spaßte folien mehr so
gepasst haben wir uns geholt
das heißt ich werde jetzt einfach mal
hier oben mit tesa zum befestigen
genau freunde das heißt dem jetzt schon
dieser rote folie drum
darauf müssen wir jetzt allerdings auch
wieder hier wird ein weißes kreuz
draufkleben dass wir haben den kleinen
verband vergessen
um diesen kleinen verband der ausguck
kümmern wir uns später das erste was
jetzt allerdings machen ist ihnen so ein
bisschen sekundenkleber holding hier
drauf und werden da jetzt einfach mal
das kreuz zu befestigen
es sieht ja echt ok aus die kunden
können wieder
allerdings geben wir uns hiermit noch
nicht zufrieden sondern freunde wir
sehen natürlich dass hier noch ein
schwarzer streifen drumrum ist das heißt
dahin werden wir jetzt einfach diesen
kleinen verband hier klemmen becquerel
küchenrolle erschwert so und nun noch
einmal hier darum wickeln und jetzt
schneide ich das hier vorne mit der
schere auch schon direkt wieder ab
freunde das heißt das medi kids meditec
medicaid heißt es glaube ich ist an
dieser stelle jetzt auch fertig also ich
wünsche euch hier mal ein
wie es aussieht dafür dass main kanal
nicht echt komplette show
das geht echt klar wenn sie mit einer
schnell auspacken will jetzt nicht weil
es hier festgeklebt und darf der
erklärte wenders ausgemacht hat das auch
nichts drin aber es sieht so aus
das gibt mir für ausgabe von 3 bis bex
alter krása jule
jo da war das trinken der essence
testleiter
also ja der sammler möchte immer das
nächste produkt bauen
als nächstes freunde möchte ich dass ihr
das hier nach baut also für den verband
sandra haben wir halt eine küchenrolle
gekauft und für das rote drumherum haben
wir das hier und für diese teile die das
eigentlich zusammenhalten haben wir
extra so wovor hat mein appetit
das ist aus dem kaufland mit lang hat
ihre mutter bei baker ist ja mega
starker altar ich dachte dann kaufe ich
auch mal passieren dass ich versucht die
augenbrauen abrasiert jude das schon
eigentlich recht vernünftig hingekriegt
es hat keine großen ein du behandelst
den scheiße behandelt den gucke ich
gesagt ich behandle ihn gut also sieht
dieser verband jetzt aus ich hätte
wirklich einfach nur die küchenrolle
genommen und hätte da zwei klebestreifen
draufgemacht die weiß rotes und das hier
hätte ich nicht mehr angemeldet dass er
nicht auch nicht angemalt und jule ist
sofort detailverliebt und sandra wolf
dass ihr noch einmal sieht es sieht
genauso aus ja freunde wir haben bisher
diesen blauen hier gemacht dann haben
wir dieses etikett fällig gestellt das
haben wir die verbände gemacht und ich
würde sagen als nächstes mache ich das
nagel
zelaya war vor dass das nagelbrett bis
hierhin geht
dafür haben wir hier nämlich extra schon
nägel king fällt auch für luca wie heißt
noch mal ein schwarzer block hatte nicht
gut bin dank leben wir hier sind gelben
streifen mal hin
dann komme ich denn dann treffen wir
hier vornehmen also den gelben rand hier
haben wir jetzt werde ich freunde der
kippe jetzt dran
stellt euch wie gesagt einfach vor dass
das so ist
die sind auf jeder seite 5 nägel da wäre
allerdings so ein bisschen so ein
kleines hier haben würde ich sagen ja
auf jeder seite drei oder so ich wünsche
mir dass sie überhaupt stehen hier die
halten nicht diese tracks mädel das hält
neben kamer
also so soll das echte nagelbrett auf
freuen und unser sieht jetzt so aus
es hält aber eine kuh marktreife als
nächstes und letztes haben wir jetzt
hier diesen job wieder ein getränk was
würde danach probieren kann dafür habe
ich einfach ein marmeladenglas genommen
und da wir den inhalt machen würde ich
sagen will du kannst du den deckel jetzt
auch unsere rot oder sonnengelb machen
[Musik]
also sieht der ganze eigentlich aus wie
gesagt mit was glauben drin im meer mit
diesem deckel roth gemacht weil wir das
hier auch orange gemacht haben haben wir
so rang schon das blut abgenommen
kunden haben wir das gemacht abgeklebt
ein echtes der hellblauen aber da ist
auch oben blau oben haben wir anderen
verschluss drauf gemacht weil hier oben
ist er auch dort damit man das ganze
haltigen wir auch machen kann die sache
ist nur das ding ist nicht komplett
dicht also wir können es nicht umdrehen
oder das ist rob also so sieht nun
dieser doccheck aus wie gesagt mit einem
orangenen inhalt anstatt den blauen
da haben wir ja auch noch dieses
nagelbrett nachgestellt also diese
treppe
dann hatten wir hier noch dieses medica
samir nachgebaut und wir haben verbände
nachgebaut und den blauen zu werden das
heißt eigentlich das kann man schon
erkenntnis dass ford lightprodukte sind
hätte tierwelt jedoch dass wir das ganze
noch mal machen und vielleicht ein paar
andere sachen nachbauen wie
beispielsweise c c oder irgendwie so da
irgendwie waffe machen oder so dann
lasst mal leiter freunde das ist was ich
allerdings von dem heutigen thema für
den block und jetzt
[Musik]